do you remember your first poem you ever
wrote I went to a creative art summer
camp in
Louisiana and this woman was my poetry
teacher and she defines writing a poem
she's like I just want you to write
something on the page that doesn't make
sense like describe the one bird you've
never seen I remember describing like a
rainbow bird and I remember thinking
like here's all these things about this
bird I'd never seen I was never good at
anything that was like took place in a
classroom and I was like I'm just going
to try and I'm just going to be like I
don't think I could make something good
but I think I could make something
that's me this is such a lovely thought
which is you know there is no right or
wrong or good or bad there's just you
you know Teddy Roosevelt said you know
comparison is the thief of joy